that got me thinking about an article
that I read about Anthony Bourdain and
Anthony Bourdain obviously he was about
as successful as as anyone could be I
mean he was a successful guy in so many
aspects and yet and yet he killed
himself and I didn't know him personally
but you know he knew people that I know
you know he was he was friends with Joe
Rogan he was he was friends with Harley
Flanagan he was friends with guys that
guys that have really good guys and so
in that way I kind of felt like I knew
what kind of a guy he was at least and
even from the outside even without
having any connections to him at all he
was the kind of guy that had just about
everything that that that most people
would want and even still I mean
obviously that wasn't enough well in the
article that I read there was a quote
from one of Anthony Bourdain's books and
the book was called a Cook's Tour he
said in this book I wanted adventures I
wanted to go up the num river to the
heart of darkness in Cambodia I wanted
to ride out into a desert on Camelback
sand and dunes in every direction
eat whole roasted lamb with my fingers I
wanted to kick snow off my boots in a
Mafia nightclub in Russia I wanted to
play with automatic weapons in pnom pen
recapture the past in a small boy stur
village in France
step into a CD neon-lit boqueria in
rural Mexico I wanted to run roadblocks
in the middle of the night blowing past
angry militia with a handful of hurled
marlboro packs experience fear
excitement wonder I wanted kicks the
kind of melodramatic thrills and chills
I'd yearned for since childhood the kind
of adventure I'd found as a little boy
in the pages of my Tintin comic books I
wanted to see the world and I wanted the
world to be just like the movies that's
what Anthony Bourdain said just like the
movies but you know what to me the world
is not like the movies the movies aren't
real they don't exist but you do and
life this life is it's better than any
movie there is movies are supposed to
provoke emotion they're supposed to make
you feel something but I have a better
idea go out into the world and actually
feel it go feel joy and love and triumph
and rapture and ecstasy and glory go
feel those things and you know with
those feelings there will be other
feelings as well there'll be sorrow and
pain and sadness and desolation and
suffering there'll be all those feelings
too but you know what that's okay that's
okay take both sides feel all of it
that's what life is those feelings those
emotions those eyes and those lows those
are life and those emotions and those
feelings are better than any movie
because they are real
so make your own comic book make your
life your own movie but actually make it
better than a movie not not better
because it's more adventurous or more
romantic or more melodramatic make it
better because it's real it's real so it
is better and you know what real comes
with some downsides real comes with some
darkness
but that's okay it's okay because when
you know the darkness the light becomes
even brighter so go out there move
toward the light move toward the light
and live live